Hi, everyone. You might know. It's 10 years since our first upload.
And hopefully you've watched professor Poliakoff top 10 video list.
If you have,
you may have come here and I'm going to name my top 10 from the other side of
the camera.
And the only caveat is I'm not going to name any that were on the professors
list. So here we go.
Number one has to be our gold bully and volt video
at the time.
No one had previously been allowed inside this Volk to film all the gold.
And I have to tell you, I'm sorry. It looked even more amazing in real life,
but all together, if you look at the bank's annual report,
it's worth 197 billion pounds.
What an incredible thing to see all that gold in one place,
really memorable experience. Next boiling water.
As we went to Everest base camp each night,
we'd boil water at a different altitude showing how the boiling point was
changing as we got higher and higher.
[Inaudible].
This was obviously a really amazing trip to do.
I think the video turned out really pretty.
And the music from Alan Stewart was also right on point
Bit of a nostalgic one here, cesium the emperor of alkaline metals.
We'd always talked about cesium reactions.
We've done quite a few over the years now,
but looking back at the early days when we first tried it with news, ingenious,
contraptions,
and the excitement of not knowing what the cesium would do in the water.
And let's see what happens ready, guys.
You might argue it was a bit of an anticlimax. I don't know.
I still think it's an amazing thing to see,
and it brings back a lot of fond memories watching this video.
Nice purple flair, really quite nice chemistry.
Another road trip. It'd be going to the mine,
just outside Stockholm in Sweden that gave its name to four elements on the
periodic table. This had a real sense of adventure.
I think it may have been the first trip we ever did.
We've reached the top
left. Oh wow.
And it really felt like we were chasing periodic table history.
Another periodic video. Favorite is the barking dog reaction.
We've done it numerous times in numerous ways,
but it wasn't until we got a really good,
slow motion camera on it that we saw this chugging of the reaction front.
As it went down the tube,
it was a bit of a surprise and really exciting to see it.
We saw the reaction in a way we hadn't seen it before
another nostalgic one remembering the early days when all these reactions were
new and exciting and we first dropped sodium in water, it went off with a bang.
We were having so much fun.
And then there was that candid moment when Pete and Neil realized some of the
sodium had come out of the action bottle onto my camera.
And they noticed while I was filming,
it was something fun to include in the video.
Oh.
I think we were all wearing safety specs.
The people who know me may know I'm really into the Apollo moon landing.
So this next video about a hypergolic reaction was really good fun.
This is the same reaction that was used to propel the lunar modules from the
moon after they'd landed. It also had a really remarkable sound.
And opening the switch.
And speaking of sound, my next choice is a video that was made for us by Dave,
from boy and a band, a good friend, and a really clever guy.
And he came to the labs,
recorded a whole bunch of sounds and turned it into this dubstep
music track,
which I thought was really ingenious and something really different on the
channel.
We love doing reactions with things that are a little bit iconic,
like say a cheeseburger or in this case,
cans of Coke here and acid and alkali.
Not only did this look spectacular and way more interesting than we thought,
I love this candid reaction from Sam Tang.
It really shows our enthusiasm for the product.
I didn't expect it to be quite so. Wow.
Last, but certainly not least hot charcoal in liquid oxygen.
This is a favorite of Neil. He loves doing it any chance he gets.
And when we pointed the slow motion camera on it,
we saw how beautiful it really was. One of the prettiest things.
Thanks.
Very much for your support over 10 years, we really appreciate it.
I'll include links on the screen to the top 10 lists.
The professor's earlier video, our Patrion.
If you want to support the project as we go forward and hopefully there'll be
well. Who knows? Maybe another 10 years. Thanks for watching.
Do you know about the unmade podcast?
This is a podcast I make with an old school friend called Tim.
You really should check it out. I'll put links down in the description,
search the unmade podcast on your player of choice.
Or we also put them on YouTube.